hey guys welcome back to brand a video
Rebecca I'm Monster World again and
today we're gonna be doing something a
little bit different here I have a quick
video of the highlights of me fighting
rket emperor vol Haziq with max level
dragon and the decimation clause real
quick if you're having trouble with
arctan bird vol huzzah click the I on
the top right or wait for the end card
at the end of the video and you'll be
taken to my Arc tempered ball huzzah
guide where we go over everything you
need to know about the fight and how to
beat him so just in case you are having
a little bit of trouble I know he's a
pretty tough boss but on screen you'll
also be seeing a timestamp to get into
the highlights because first off I do
want to show off the build on my
thoughts so you could just click to that
time if you just want to see the
highlights so first up is my bill I ran
with the decimation clause because of
the dragon element in the high elder
suit and plus I'm just really a big fan
of dual blades the armor I ran is the
Dragon King alpha nerd gurgaon teh male
b-ball hizaki bracers gamma nirgun say
coil beta and Valhalla creams beta for
the decorations I had two dragon jewels
to crit jewels a tenderizer jewel to ko
jewels one my sigil and one sedated
jewel the overall skills came to full
dragon attack weakness ex-boy in
effluvium resistance which was majorly
helped by the fall huzzah Greaves since
I didn't need to spend so much on the
mice modules only one of them was needed
to get the full resistance level to
attack boost power Pro longer stamina
surge and Slugger and then ending it
with a level one free meal from the
sedated jewel I managed to beat him in
roughly about thirty minutes with two
faints but my fastest run was about 15
to 20 minutes but no faints
but Savi I wasn't recording at the time
it was pretty late and I didn't feel
like doing it because I was super tired
and I just want to get the fight over
with I saw tons of opportunities while
watching the gameplay back where I could
have cut the time down a bit making for
a faster run which will probably help me
in the future but for this run I went
through a few mistakes such as dying a
bit dying two simple attacks not getting
decent damage punishes when I had the
chance
stuff like that either way though enjoy
the highlights with some intense music
by epidemic sound link in the
description and with that sub if you're
new I cover the solo guides a monster on
a roll on most of the higher up monsters
event quests every week to let everybody
know what to do and how to beat them and
tips and tricks for monster honorable to
make everyone a better hunter and with
that guys let's get started with the
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]